[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGIO GUADARRAMA:
Today, we are going
to talk about reinforcement
learning, how you can apply
to many different problems.
So hopefully, by
the end of the talk,
you will know how to use
reinforcement learning
for your problem, for
your applications, what
other things we are
doing at Google with all
these new technology.
So let me go a little bit--
do you remember when you try
to do something difficult
that was hard that
you need to try a lot?
For example, when you learned
how to walk, do you remember?
I don't remember.
But it's pretty hard
because nobody tells you
exactly how to do it.
You just keep trying.
And eventually, you're able
to stand up, keep the balance,
wobble around,
and start walking.
So what if we want to teach this
cute little robot how to walk?
Imagine-- how you will do that?
How would you tell
this robot how to walk?
So what we are
going to do today is
learn how we can do that
with machine learning.
And the reason for
that is because if we
want to do this by
calling a set of rules,
it will be really hard.
What kind of rules would we
put in code that can actually
make this robot the walk?
We have to do
coordination, balance.
It's really difficult.
And then they probably
would just fall over.
And we don't know what
to change in the code.
Instead of that, we're
going to use machine
learning to learn from it.
So the agenda for today
is going to be this.
We are going to cover
very quickly what
is supervised learning,
reinforcement learning, what
is TF-Agents, these things
we just talk about it.
And we will go through
multiple examples.
So you can see we can build up
different pieces to actually
go and solve this problem,
teach this robot how to walk.
And finally, we will have some
take home methods that you
can take with you all today.
So how many of you know
what is supervised learning?
OK.
That's pretty good.
For those of you who
don't know, let's go
to a very simple example.
So we're going to have
some inputs, in this case,
like an image.
And we're going to
pass through our model,
and we're going to
put in some outputs.
In this case, there's going
to be a cat or the dog.
And then, we're going to tell
you what is the right answer.
So that's the key aspect.
In supervising learning,
we tell you the label.
What is the right answer?
So you can modify your model
and learn from these mistakes.
In this case, you
might use a neural net.
We have a lot of ways
that you can learn.
And you can modify
those connections
to basically learn over time
what is the right answer.
The thing that
supervised learning need
is a lot of labels.
So many of you probably
heard about IMAGENET.
It's a data set
collected by Stanford.
It took like over two
years and $1 million
to gather all this data.
And they could annotate
millions of images with labels.
Say, in this image, there's
a container received.
There's a motor scooter.
There's a leopard.
And then, you label
all these images
so your model can learn from it.
And that worked
really well where
you can have all these
labels, and then you
can train your model from it.
The question is like, how
will you provide the labels
for this robot?
What is the right actions?
I don't know.
It's not that clear.
What will be the right
answer for this case?
So we are going to take a
different approach, what
is like reinforcement learning.
Instead of trying to
provide the right answer--
like in a classical setting,
you will go to class,
and they tell you what
is the right answers.
You know, you study, this is
the answer for this problem.
We already know what
is the right answer.
In reinforcement
learning, we assume
we don't know what
is the right answer.
We need to figure
it out ourselves.
It's more like a kid.
It's playing around, putting
these labels together.
And eventually, they're able to
stack it up together, and stand
up.
And that gives you
like some reward.
It's like, oh, you feel proud of
it, and then you keep doing it.
Which are the actions you took?
Not so relevant.
So let's formalize a little more
what reinforcement learning is
and how you can
actually make these
into more concrete examples.
Let's take a simpler example,
like this little game
that you're trying to play.
You want to bounce the
ball around, move the pile
at the bottom left or
right, and then you
want to hit all these
bricks, and play this game,
clear up, and win the game.
So we're going to have
this notion of an agent
or program that's going
to get some reservation.
In this case, a friend is
going to look at the game.
What is the ball, where are
the brakes, what is the puzzle,
and take an action.
I'm going to move to the left or
I'm going to move to the right.
And depending where you
move, the ball will drop,
or you actually start keeping
the ball bouncing back.
And we're going to have
this notion of reward,
what is like when
you do well, we
want you to get positive reward,
so you reinforce that behavior.
And when you do poorly, you
will get negative reward.
So we can define simple
rules and simple things
to basically call this
behavior as a reward function.
Every time you hit a
brick, you get 10 points.
Which actions do you need
to do to hit the brick?
I don't tell you.
That's what you need to learn.
But if you do it, I'm going
to give the 10 points.
And if you clear
all the bricks, I'm
going to give you
actually a hundred
points to encourage
you to actually play
this game very well.
And every time the
ball drops, you
lose 50 points, which
means, probably not
a good idea to do that.
And if you let the ball drop
three times, game is over,
you need to stop the game.
So the good thing is about
the reinforcement learning,
you can apply to many
different problems.
And here are some examples
that over the last year people
have been applying
reinforcement learning.
And it goes from recommender
instance in YouTube, data
set to cooling, real robots.
You can apply to
math, chemistry,
or a cute little robot
in the middle, and things
as complex as they go.
Like DeepMind applied
to AlphaGo and beat
the best player in the world by
using reinforcement learning.
Now, let me switch a little bit
to TF-Agents and what it is.
So main idea of TF-Agents like
doing reinforcement learning
is not very easy.
It requires a lot of
tools and a lot of things
that you need to
build on your own.
So we built this library
that we use at Google,
and we open source
so everybody can
use it to make reinforcement
learning a lot easier to use.
So we make it very robust.
It's scalable, and it's
good for beginners.
If you are new to
RL, we have a lot
of notebooks,
example documentation
that you can start working on.
And also, for
complex problems, you
can apply to real
complex problems
and use it for realistic cases.
For people who want to
create their own algorithm,
we also make it easy
to add new algorithms.
It's well tested and
easy to configure.
And furthermore, we build
it on top of TensorFlow 2.0
that you probably heard
over at Google I/O before.
And we make it in such a way so
it's developing and debugging
is a lot easier.
You can use see TF-Eager mode
and Keras and TF functions
to make things a
lot easier to build.
Very modular, very extensible.
Let me cover a little bit the
main pieces of the software,
so then when we go
through the examples,
you have a better sense.
On the left side, we have
all the data collection.
When we play this game, we
are going to collect data.
We are going to play the game.
We're collecting data
so we can learn from it.
And on the right
side, we're going
to have a training pipeline.
When we have the
data, like a data set,
or log in, or games we play,
we're going to transfer any
proof or model-- in this
case, the neural net--
I'm going to deploy, collect
more data, and repeat.
So now, let me hand
it over to Eugene,
who is going to go over
the CartPole example.
EUGENE BREVDO: Thanks, Sergio.
Yeah, so the first example
we're going to go over
is a problem called Cartpole.
This is one of the
classical control problems
where imagine that you
have a pole in your hand,
and it wants to fall
over because of gravity.
And you kind of have to move
your hand left and right
to keep it upright.
And if it falls
over, then game over.
If you move off the screen
by accident, then game over.
So let's make that a
little bit more concrete.
In this environment, the
observation is not the images
that you see here.
Instead, it's a four
vector containing
angles and velocities of
the pole and the cart.
The actions are
the values 0 and 1
representing being able
to take a left or a right.
And the reward is the value
1.0 every time step or frame
that the pole is up and
hasn't fallen over more
than 15 degrees from vertical.
And once it has,
the episode ends.
OK, so if you were to implement
this problem or environment
yourself, you would subclass the
TF-Agents by environment class,
and you would provide
two properties.
One is called the
observation aspect,
and that defines what
the observations are.
And you would implement
the action spec property,
and that describes what
actions the environment allows.
And there are two major methods.
One is reset, which
resets the environment
and brings the pole back
to the center and vertical.
And the set method, which
accepts the action and updates
any internal state and emits
the observation and the reward
for that time stamp.
Now, for this
particular problem,
you don't have to do that.
We support OpenAi, which
is a very popular framework
for environments in Python.
And you can simply load
CartPole from that.
That's the first line.
And now you can perform
some introspection.
You can interrogate the
environment, say what is
Observation Spec.
Here, you can see that it's
a forward vector of floating
point values.
Again, describing the angle
and velocities of the pole.
And the Action Spec
is a scalar integer
picking on values 0 and 1,
representing left and right.
So if you had your own
policy that you had built,
maybe a scripted
policy, you would
be able to interact
with the environment
by loading it, building
your policy object,
resetting the environment
to get an initial state,
and then iterating
over and over again,
passing the observation or
the state to the policy,
getting an action from that,
passing the action back
to the environment, maybe
calculating your return, which
is the sum of the
rewards or all steps.
Now, the interesting
part comes when
you want to make
a tenable policy
and you wanted to learn from its
successes in the environment.
To do that, we put a
neural network in the loop.
So the neural network takes
in the observations, an image.
In this case-- and the algorithm
that we're talking about is
called policy gradients,
also known as reinforce--
it's going to emit probabilities
over the actions that
can be taken.
So in this case,
it's going to emit
a probability of taking a left
or a probability of taking
a right, and that's
parameterized
by the weight of the
neural network called data.
And ultimately, the
goal of this algorithm
is going to be modifying
the neural network over time
to maximize what's called
the expected return.
And as I mentioned,
the return is
the sum of the rewards over
the duration of the episode.
And you can calculate it--
by just this expectation,
it's difficult to calculate
analytically.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to sample episodes
by playing, we're going
to get trajectories,
and we're going to store
those trajectories.
These are observation action
pairs over the episode.
We're going to add them up.
And that's our Monte Carlo
estimate of the return.
OK?
And we're going to
make a couple of checks
to convert that expectation
optimization problem into a sum
that we can optimize
using gradient descent.
I'm going to skip
over some of the math,
but basically, what we use
is something called the log
trick to convert
this gradient problem
into the gradient over the
outputs of the neural network.
That's that log pi
theta right there.
That's the output
of the network.
And we're going to multiply
that by the Monte Carlo
estimate of the returns.
And we're going to average
over the timestamps
within the episode and over
many batches of episodes.
Putting this into code--
and by the way, we
implement this for you,
but that's kind of
a pseudo code here.
You get this experience
when you're training,
you extract its rewards, and
you do a cumulative sum type
operation to
calculate the returns.
Then, you take the observations
over all the time steps,
and you calculate the lotus,
the log probabilities coming out
of the neural network.
You pass those to a
distribution object--
this is a TensorFlow probability
to get the distributions
over the action.
And then you can calculate
the full log probability
of the actions that were
taken in your trajectories
and your logs, and
calculate this approximation
of the expectation
and take its gradient.
OK, so as an end
user, you don't need
to worry about that too much.
What you want to do is
you load your environment,
you wrap it in something
called a TF Py environment.
And that's easy as the
interaction between the Python
problem setting
and the environment
and the neural network,
which is being executed
by the TensorFlow runtime.
Now, you can also create
your neural network.
And here, you can
write your own.
And basically, it's a
sequence of Keras layers.
Those of you who are
familiar with Keras,
that makes it very easy to
describe your own architecture
for the network.
We provide a number
of neural networks.
This one accepts a
number of parameters that
configure the architecture.
So here, there are two
fully connected layers
with sizes 32 and 64.
You pass this
network and the specs
associated with the
environment to the agent class.
And now you're ready to
collect that and to train.
So to collect data, you
need a place to store it.
And Sergio we'll talk about
this more in the second example.
But basically, we
use something called
replay buffers that are going
to store these trajectories.
And we provide a
number of utilities
that will collect
the data for you,
and they're called drivers.
So this driver takes
the environment,
takes the policy exposed
by the agent path
and a number of callbacks.
And what it's
going to do is it's
going to iterate collecting
data, interacting
with the environment, sending
it actions, collecting
observations, sending those to
the policy, does that for you.
And each time it does
that, for every time stop,
it's stores that in
the replay buffer.
So to train, you iterate
calling a driver run, which
populates the replay buffer.
Then you pull out all of the
trajectories in the replay
buffer with gather
all, you pass those
to agent.train, which updates
the underlying neural networks.
And because policy gradients
is in something called an
on policy algorithm,
all that hard earned
collected data that
you've done, you
have to throw it away
and collect more.
OK?
So that said, CartPole is
a fairly straightforward
classical problem,
as I mentioned.
And policy gradients is a
fairly standard, somewhat simple
algorithm.
And after about 400 iterations
of playing the game,
you can see that
whereas you started
with a random policy, that
can't keep the pole up at all.
After 400 iterations
of playing the game,
you basically have
a perfect policy.
And if you were to look
at your TensorBoard
while you're training,
you'd see a plot
like this, which shows that
as the number of episodes
that are being collected
increases the total return--
which is the sum of the
rewards over the episode--
goes up pretty consistently.
And at around 400, 500 episodes,
we have a perfect algorithm
that runs for 200 steps, at
which point the episode says,
all right, you're good, you win.
And then you're done.
OK, so I'm going to hand
it back over to Sergio
to talk about Atari
and deep Q-learning.
SERGIO GUADARRAMA:
Thank you, again.
So now we're going
back to this example
that I talked at the beginning
about how to play this game.
And now we're going to
go through more details
how this actually works, and
how this deep Q-learning works
to help us in this case.
So let's go back to our setting.
Now we have our
environment where
we're going to be playing.
We're going to get
some observations,
in this case, frames.
The agent role is to
produce different actions
like go left with the paddle or
go right, and get some rewards
in the process, and
then improve over time
by basically incorporating
those rewards into the model.
Let's take a little
step and say,
what if while I'm
playing Breakout,
I have seen how far
what I've been doing,
the ball is going
somewhere, I'm moving
in the centered direction, and
then, what should I do now?
Should I go to the right
or should I go to the left?
If I knew what is going to
happen, it will be very easy.
If I knew oh, the balls
are going to go this way,
the things are going to be
that, that will be easy.
But that one, we
don't easily know.
We don't know what's going
to happen in the future.
Instead, what we're
going to do, we
are going to try to estimate
if I move to the right,
maybe the ball will drop.
It's more likely
that the ball drop
because I'm moving in
the opposite direction
that the ball is going.
And if I move to the
left, on the contrary,
I'm going to hit the ball
I'm going to hit some bricks,
I'm getting closer to
clear all the bricks.
So the idea is like
I want to learn
a model that can estimate that.
If this action is going to make
me go better into the future
or is going to make it go worse.
And that's something that
we call expected return.
So is this nothing that
Eugene was talking before,
that before we were just
computing, just summing
on the rewards.
And here, we're
going to say, I want
to estimate this action,
how much reward it's
going to give me in the future.
And then, I choose
the thing what
it's according to my
estimate is the best action.
So we can formulate
this with using math.
It's basically like an
expectancy over the sum
of the rewards into the future.
And that's when I call this
Q function, or like critic.
It's also a critic because
it's going to basically tell us
given some state and
possible actions, which
action is actually better?
What I criticize in some way,
like if you take this action,
my expectation of the
return is very high.
And you take a different
action, my expectation is low.
And then what we're
going to do, we're
going to learn
these Q functions.
Because we don't know.
We don't know what's
going to happen.
But by playing,
we can learn what
is the expected return by
comparing our expectation
with the actual returns.
So we are going to use our Q
function-- and in this case,
a neural net--
to learn this model.
And while we have
a learned model,
then we can just take the best
action according to our model
and play the game.
So conceptually, this looks
similar to what we saw before.
We're going to have
another neural net.
And this case, the
output is going
to be the Q values,
this expectation
of our future returns.
And the idea is we're going
to get an observation,
in this case, the frames.
We're going to maybe have
some history about it.
And then we're going to
preview some Q value, which
like our current expectation
if I move to the left,
and my current expectation
if I move to the right.
And then I'm going to I
compare my expectation,
what will actually happen.
And if basically my
expectation is too high,
I'm going to lower down.
And if my expectation is too
low, I'm going to increase it.
So that way, we're
going to change
the weight of this network to
basically improve over time
by playing this game.
We go back to how you
do this into code.
Basically, we're going
to log this environment.
In this case, from the
suite Atari where it's also
available for an OpenAi.
I'm going to say, OK,
load the Breakout game.
And now, we are ready to play.
We're going to have
some reservations,
we'll define what
kind of reservations
we have from this case
where it's frames of like 84
by 84 pixels, and we also have
multiple answers we can take.
In this game, we can
only go left and right,
but there are other
games in this suite that
can have different actions.
Maybe jumping, firing,
and doing other things
that different games have.
So now, we want to do that
notion what we said before.
We're going to define
this Q network.
Remember, it's a neural
net that is going
to represent these Q values.
I'm going to have
some parameters that
define how many layers,
how many things we want
to have on all those things.
And then, we're going to
have the Q agent that's
going to take the network,
and an optimizer which
is going to basically be able to
improve this network over time,
given some experience.
So this experience,
we're going to assume
we have collected some data
and we have played the game.
And maybe not very
well at the beginning,
because we are doing random
actions, for example.
So we're not playing very well.
but we can get some
experience, and then we
can improve over time basically.
We try to improve our estimates.
Every time we improve,
we play a little better.
And then we collect more data.
And then the idea
is that this agent
is going to have a
train method that
is going to go through
this experience,
and is going to
improve over time.
In general, for cases like games
or environments are too slow,
we don't want to play one
game of the time, you know.
These computers can play
multiple games in parallel.
So we have this notion
that parallel environments,
you can play multiple copies of
the same game at the same time.
So we can make
learning a lot faster.
And in this case, we are
playing four games in parallel,
we're going to have for a policy
that we've got just defined.
And in parallel, we can
just play four games
at the same time.
So the agent in
this case will try
to play four games
at the same time.
And that way, we'll get
a lot of more experience
and can learn a lot faster.
So as we mentioned before, where
we have collected all this data
by playing this
game, in this case,
we don't want to
throw away the data.
We can use it to learn it.
So we're going to have
this replay buffer, which
is going to keep all the
data we're collecting,
like different games will
go in different positions
so we don't mix the games.
But we're going to just throw
all the data in some replay
buffer.
And that into the
code, it's simple.
We have this environment.
We cleared the replay buffer
we have already defined.
And then basically, using
the driver, and then
more important than this,
add to the replay buffer.
Every time you play, take
an action in this game,
add it to the replay buffer.
So later, the agent contains
all that experience.
And because DQN is
our policy method--
what is different than their
previous method was on policy--
in this case, we can
actually use all the data.
We can keep all the data
around and keep training
on all data too.
We don't need you to throw away.
And that's very
important because we
make it more efficient.
What we're going
to do when we have
called the data and
this replay buffer,
we're going to do a sample.
We're going to sample a
different set of games,
different parts of the game.
I'm going to say, OK, let's
try to replay the game
and maybe take a different
outcome this time.
What action will you take if
you were in the same situation?
Maybe you move to the
left, and the ball drop.
So maybe now you want
to move to the right.
So that's the ways
the model is going
to be learning, by basically
sample games that you played
before, and now improve
your key function is going
to change the way you behave.
So now let's try to put
these things back together.
Let's go slowly because
there's a lot of pieces.
So we have our Q
network we're going
to use to define the
DQN agent in this case.
We're going to have
the replay buffer where
we're going to put
all the data we're
collecting what we played.
We have this driver,
which basically
drive the agent in the game.
So it's going to
basically driving
the agent making play and
add it to the replay buffer.
And then, once we
have enough data,
we can basically
iterate with that data.
We can iterate, get batches of
experience, different samples.
And that's what we're going
to do to train the agent.
So we are going to
alternate, collect more data,
and train the agent.
So every time we collect,
we train the agent,
the agent gets a
little better, and we
want to collect more
data, and we alternate.
At the end, what we want to
do is evaluate this agent.
So we have a method
that says, OK, I
want to compute some metrics.
For example, how
long are you playing
the game, how many
points are you getting,
all those things that
we want to compare
metrics and aggressively
have these methods.
OK, how about take all these
metrics in this environment,
take the agent
policy, and evaluate
for multiple games, multiple
episodes, and multiple things.
How this actually looks
like is something like that.
For example, in
the Breakout game,
the curves looks like that.
At the beginning, we
don't score any points.
We don't know how
to move the pole,
the ball just keep
dropping, and we just
lose the game over and over.
Eventually, we figure out
that by moving the paddle
in different directions,
the ball bounced back,
and it started
hitting the bricks.
And about 4 or 5 million
frames, they multilaterally
learn how to actually
play this game.
And you can see
around 4 or 5 million
frames, basically, the
model gets very good scores
around 100 points.
It's breaking all these
things, all these points,
and you know, clear
all the bricks.
We also put graphs
of different games
like Pong, which is basically
two different paddles trying
to bounce the ball between them.
Enduro, Qbert, there's
another like 50 or 60
games in this suite.
And you can basically just
change one line of code
and play a different game.
I'm not going to go
through those details,
but just to make clear that it's
simple to play different games.
Now, let me hand it
over back to Eugene,
who's going to talk a little
more into the Minitaur.
Thanks, again.
EUGENE BREVDO: OK, so our
third and final example
is the problem of
the Minitaur robot
and kind of goes back to
one of the first slides
that Sergio showed at the
beginning of the talk,
learning for walk.
So there is a real robot.
It's called the Minitaur.
And here, it's kind
of failing hard.
We're going to see
if we can fix that.
The algorithm we're going to
use is called Soft Actor Critic.
OK.
So again, on the bottom is
some images of the robot.
And you can see it
looks a little fragile.
We want to train it,
and we want to avoid
breaking it in it beginning
when our policy can't really
stay up.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to model it in a physics
simulator called PyBullet,
and that's what
you see at the top.
And then, once we've
trained it, we're
confident about the
policy on that version,
we're going to transfer
it back into the robot
and do some final fine tuning.
And here, we're going to focus
on the training and simulation.
So I won't go into the
mathematical details
of the Soft Actor Critic, but
here's some fundamental aspects
of that algorithm.
One is that it can handle both
discrete and continuous action
spaces.
Here, we're going to be
controlling some motors
and actuators, so it's a
fairly continuous action space.
It's data-efficient, meaning
that all this hard earned data
that you run in simulation
or you got from the robot,
you don't have to throw it
away while you're training,
you can keep it
around for retraining.
Also, the training is stable.
Compared to some
other algorithms,
this one is less likely to
diverge during training.
And finally, one of
the fundamental aspects
is that it's Soft
Actor Critic, it
combines an actor neural network
and a critic neural network
to accelerate training
and to keep it stable.
Again, so Minitaur,
you can basically
do a pip install of
PyBullet, and you'll
get Minitaur for free.
You can load it using the
PyBullet fleet with TF-Agents.
And if you were to look
at this environment,
you'd see that there are
about 28 sensors on the robot
that return floating
point values,
different aspects of
the configuration where
you are, forces, velocities,
things like that.
And the action, there are
eight actuators on the robot.
It can apply a force--
positive or negative,
minus 1 to 1--
for each of those
eight actuators.
Now, here's kind of bringing
together the whole setup.
You can load four of
these simulations,
have them running
in parallel, and try
to maximize the number of
course that you're using
when you're collecting data.
And to do that, we provide the
parallel Py environment, which
Sergio spoke about, wrapped
in TF Py environment.
And now, we get
down to the business
of setting up the neural network
architecture for the problem.
First, we create
the actor network.
And so what the actor
network is going to do
is it's going to take these
sensor observations, this 28
vector, and it's going to limit
samples of actuator values.
And those samples are
random draws from,
in this case, Gaussian
or normal distribution.
So as a result, this
action distribution network
takes something called
a projection network.
And we provide a number of
standard projection networks.
This one emits samples from
a Gaussian distribution.
And the neural network
that feeds into it
is going to be setting
up the hyperparameters
of that distribution.
Now, the critic network,
which is in the top right,
is going to take a combination
of the current sensor
observations and
the action sample
that the actor network
emitted, and it's
going to estimate
the expected return.
How much longer,
given this action,
is my robot going to stay up?
How well is it going to gallop?
And that is going to be
trained from the trajectories
from the rewards that
you're collecting.
And that, in turn, is going
to help train the actor.
So you pass these
networks and these specs
to the Soft Actor Critic
agent, and you can
look at its collection policy.
And that's the thing
that you're going
to pass on the driver
to start collecting data
and interacting with
the environment.
So I won't go into the
details of actually doing
that because it's literally
identical to the deep
Q-learning example before.
You need the replay buffer,
and you use the driver
and you go through
the same motion.
What I'm going to
show is what you
should expect to see
in the TensorBoard
while you're training
the simulation.
On the top, you see the
average episode length,
the average return as a function
of the number of environment
steps that you've taken--
the number of time steps.
On the bottom, you
see the same thing.
But on the x-axis, you
see the number of episodes
that you've gone through.
And what you can see is
that after about 13,000,
14,000 simulated episodes,
we're starting to really learn
how to walk and gallop.
The episode lengths
get longer because it
takes longer to fall down.
And the average
return also goes up
because it's also a function
of how long we stay up
and how well we can gallop.
So again, if this is
a pilot simulation,
a rendering of the Minitaur,
at the very beginning,
when the policy just
emits random values,
the neural network
emits random values--
it's randomly initialized--
and it can barely stay up,
it basically falls over.
About halfway through
training, it's
starting to be able to get
up, maybe make a few steps,
falls over.
If you apply some external
forces, it'll just fall over.
By about 16,000
iterations of this,
it's a pretty robust policy.
And it can stand, it can gallop.
If there's an external
force pushing it over,
it'll be able to get
back up and keep going.
And once you have
that trained policy,
you can transfer it,
export it as a safe model,
put it on the actual robot,
and then start the fine tuning
process.
Once you fine tuned it, you
have a pretty neat robot.
In my head, when I
look at this video,
I think of the "Chariots
of Fire" theme song.
I don't know if you've ever
seen it, but it's pretty cool.
So now, I'm going to
return it back to Sergio
to provide some final words.
SERGIO GUADARRAMA:
Thank you, again.
So pretty cool, no?
You can get from
the beginning how
to learn to walk and naturally
make these in simulation.
But then, we can transfer
it to a real robot
and make it work
into a real robot.
So that's part of the
goal of TF-Agents.
We want to make
our role very easy.
You can download the code,
you can scan over there
and go to the GitHub,
start playing with it.
We have already a lot of
different environments,
more than we talked today.
There's many more.
So we just covered three
examples, but you can go there,
there's many other
environments available.
We are hoping that
Unity ML-Agents
come soon so you can also
interact with the Unity
renders.
Maybe there's some of
you who are actually
interesting to contribute
into your own environments,
your own problems.
We are also very happy
to take proof requests
and contributions to everything.
For those of you who say, OK,
those games are really good.
The games looks nice, but
I have my own problem.
What do I do?
So let's go back to
the beginning when
we talk about you can
define your environment,
you can define your own task.
This is the main piece
that you need to follow.
This is the API
you need to follow
to bring your task or
your problem to TF-Agents.
You define the specifications
of your observations,
like what things can I see?
Can I see images, can I see
numbers, what that means?
What actions
available do I have?
Do I have two options, three
options, 10 different options?
What are the
possibilities I have?
And then the reset
method because as we say,
while we're learning,
we need to keep trying.
So we need to reset
and start again.
And then the stop
function where it's
like, if I give you an
action, what will happen?
How the environment, how
the task is going to evolve?
What is this state
is going to change?
And you need to
tell me the reward.
Am I doing well?
Am I going in the
right direction,
or am I going in
the wrong direction?
So I can learn from it.
So this is the
main piece of code
that you will need to implement
to solve your own problem.
Additionally, we only talked
about three algorithms,
but we have many more
in the code base.
You can see here, there
are many more coming.
So there's a lot of variety
of different algorithms
have different
strands that you can
apply to different problems.
So you can just try
different combinations
and see which one actually
works for your problem.
And also, we are taking
contributions for other people
who say, oh, I have
this algorithm,
I want to implement this
one, I have this new idea,
and maybe you can solve other
problems with your algorithm.
And furthermore, we also apply
these not only to this game,
but we apply at Google,
for example, in robotics.
In this really complex
problem, that we
have multiple robots trying
to learn how to grasp objects
and moving to different places.
So in this case, we have
all these robots just trying
to grasp and fail
at the beginning.
And eventually, they learned
like, oh, where is the object?
How do I move the hand?
How do I close the gripper
in the proper place?
And now how do I grasp it?
And this is a very
complex task you can
solve with reinforced learning.
Furthermore, you can also
solve many other problems
for simple recommender systems
like YouTube recommendations,
Google Play, Navigation, News.
Those are many other problems
that you can basically
say, I want to optimize for my
objective, my long term value.
Not only the short term, but
like the long term value.
And that is really
good for that when
you want to optimize
for the long term
value, not only the short term.
Finally, we have
put a lot of effort
to make this code
available and make
it usable for a lot of people.
But at Google, we also
defined these AI principles.
So when we developed all this
code, we make it available,
we follow these principles.
We want to make it sure that it
is used for things that benefit
the society that doesn't
reinforce unfair bias, that
doesn't discriminate,
that this built
for tests for safety,
privacy, in the beginning
it's accountable.
We keep very high standards.
And we also want to
make sure that everybody
who uses this code also
embraces those principles
and trying to make it better.
And there's many applications
we want to pursue.
We don't want to be
this used for harming
and all these damaged things
that we know will happen.
Finally, I want to
thank the whole team.
You know, it's not just Eugene
and me, we made this happen.
There's other people behind.
These are the
TF-Agents over here.
There's a lot of
contributors that
have contributed
to the code, and we
are very proud of
all the work they
have done to make
this happen, to make
this possible to be open source
and available for everyone.
So as we said before,
we want all of you
to join us in GitHub.
Go to the web page, download
it, start playing with it.
A really good place is go to
the collapse on their notebooks
and say, OK, I want to
try the REINFORCE example,
I want to try the DQN or
the Soft Actor Critic.
We have notebooks you
can play, Google Cloud
will run for you
all these examples.
And also, you have issues of
pole requests, we welcome.
So we want you to be
part of their community,
contribute to make
this a lot better.
And furthermore,
we are also looking
for new applications,
what all of you
can do with these new tools.
There's a lot of new
problems you can apply this,
and we are looking
forward to it.
So thank you very much,
and hope to see you around.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]